it was it was great you know growing up
in the uk uh up north
you know the bar is very low for
culinary ability so literally going
outside of the uk is like holy [ __ ]
stuff tastes great mm-hmm everything
there's not a best welsh
dish you don't have wash dishes oh we
have some we have uh washcakes
cakes what's a welsh cake it's like like
a kind of like a i don't know how to
describe it it's like
a sponge cake or no no no can you pull
it up maybe well it's like this weird
like raisin-esque like pastry
with some kind of uh icing on it i can't
remember i i never really liked it
but people loved it
and then like i had something called
which is like butter brief yeah there's
parra which is like bread butter breathe
it's
what is what is this so that's the welsh
cake is this water
oh that looks like they look like a
pancake yeah they look like scarns
raisin pancake
um wait was it scones i swear there's
something else as well sometimes you say
scones not scones or something or scones
yes
you see scones no i say scones i don't
know why scones
scones they america
scones in america no no scones british
people say scones do we say scones
north or south i've always said scones
yeah i always say scones oh when i grew
up
something on a hill that's apparently
the name of the welsh cake i don't know
something on a hill we had leek soup
that was a dish
what
uh what do you call
the meal that you have in the evening
tea
what what
[ __ ] northerners man
there's a specific australians that call
it that so i've had to adapt because i
underst nobody understood what i was
saying because it doesn't make sense it
doesn't make sense okay pov you wake up
in north north uh you know
uk yeah uh you wake up you have
breakfast yeah right it hits 12 o'clock
you have dinner yes yeah and then it
gets to 6 p.m you have tea
not tea the drink tea the meal yeah i'll
ask my parents what's for tea and then
they'll tell me and it's even now yeah
it's beans on toast this is why i've
understood the t equals dinner thing
i've never understood the dinner equals
lunch thing yeah that's the thing
that confuses me more like like because
the point is you have dinner in your
vocabulary and you just choose not to
put it for [ __ ] dinner it's like this
is this is like this is the one thing
northerners and southerners and england
can never [ __ ] agree on when you grow
up in the place in a certain place you
rarely go to like south england if
you're from north england do you really
go to north england if you're from south
south
there is there's a real like north south
divide travel a lot in the uk just out
of the uk yeah people always
it's like 90 percent actually it's it's
cheaper a lot of the time yeah it's
cheaper yeah yeah because like trains in
england are so expensive
and like i remember like there was this
news article about how two students in
like two different universities wanted
like uh two friends from two different
universities wanted to meet each other
so they figured out that flying to
[ __ ] spain was cheaper via easyjet
was cheaper than getting a train to like
meet each other
so if you wanted to go from uh
london to wales where i live it's uh
it's a three-hour journey and it's about
120 bucks
for a really [ __ ] train yeah it's not
it's not like a shinkansen where it's
nice yeah you feel comfortable there's
no outlets you're very lucky if you get
one yeah and uh that's like that some of
the trains are horrible as well yeah
basically like very expensive as a
student to like go anywhere you need to
book your train like three weeks in
advance get the [ __ ] advanced ticket
and you better hope that you get that
exact training yeah three weeks later so
you better
and also like um you know
easyjet and ryanair would often have
deals where if you flew without any
luggage you printed off your boarding
ticket you could get tickets for like 15
dollars to some european places [ __ ]
so it's like why the [ __ ] would you ever
like go up north or go down yeah yeah
that's true um so that's yeah so you
wouldn't really interact so
naturally i never really heard people
saying
uh lunch and dinner for
lunch and dinner but now i now okay now
i say lunch and dinner because if i say
dinner and tea everyone thinks i'm a
[ __ ] weirdo
so i have rightly so but right besides
that's right northerners i said it but
after like after like you know one or
two days of being back in wales i'll
start adapting back
assimilating back into the culture
become one of them
and i'll say
yeah so we say dinner for lunch and tea
for dinner yeah but it's weird because
you it's like do you want tea but it's
like a you understand you just know
depending on how it's been said or you
read the the time of the day
what if you ask for tea at like seven
you just know you just know what's being
asked
you would say can i have some tea or can
i have tea no but can i have some tea
can also mean can i have some dinner
someone could be like i'm going to make
tea
that could mean a meal or that could
mean a couple sometimes people suggest
say cuppa i don't really like the word
cuppa a copper
because some australians especially
those that have british parents
they sometimes say tea for dinner even
in australia and that really yeah my
people like i i have a i i had a few
friends back in high school who had
british parents obviously from the north
and they yeah they used to say tea and
i'm like
i don't even drink tea bro coffee all
the way and then when i realized yeah
and then when i realized they were
talking about like the meal tea i was
like
what what like do you drink tea with
every meal like what does that mean
how british can you get